MALE SPEAKER: Ladies and
gentleman, Dan Kaufman,
Director of Google ATAP.
[APPLAUSE]
DAN KAUFMAN: Hey.
Thank you.
Good morning, everybody.
I am Dan Kaufman.
One year ago,
almost to this day,
Google asked me to come
and help lead ATAP.
And I remember sitting
in my hotel room,
watching the ATAP
I/O presentation,
and I was just
fascinated with this idea
that we could bridge the gap
between our physical world
and our digital lives.
And I was moved
by this insistence
that we remember our humanity,
that we take our human nature
and bet it in technology.
And I could not
wait to come here.
And now it's one year later,
and I'm the head of ATAP,
and I get to share
with all of you
some of the stuff we've been
working on over the last year.
And I could not be more excited.
We have a completely
packed show today.
We're going to be like,
right up to the edge,
and so I'm just going to give
you a very brief overview
of what we're going to do.
And then we're just
going to get to it.
So one thing I get asked a
lot, when I go out around
and I talk about ATAP, is
what does success mean.
How do you measure success.
How do you know
you're successful.
What becomes success.
So we'll talk a
little bit about that.
Then we're going to
get you caught up,
and give you an update on
projects Jacquard and Soli,
two projects we showed
extremely early.
AUDIENCE: Woo
DAN KAUFMAN: Yes, woo!
We showed you some really
early prototypes of that.
And we're going to show you how
it's made its journey, as we
worked with some of
you, as developers
and some commercial partners on
its way to becoming a product.
And then of course, we got to
talk about Aura, who does not
want to talk about
Aura, everybody
wants to talk about Aura.
Yes?
[APPLAUSE]
So we got an update for you.
And then finally, as has been
our tradition over the last two
years, we're going to end
with a new spotlight story.
Except this year, we've
got a really special twist.
And I hope you like it.
So let's first
talk about success,
and what success means to us.
In order for me to
tell you what success
means for a project in ATAP,
I have to take you back
to the beginning.
Everything in ATAP starts
with a person, and a passion,
and an idea.
And that idea is often
a little bit crazy.
It sort of borders right on that
line between what's possible,
and what's impossible.
And so the first thing we do
is, we do a deep scientific dive
to try to find out and make
sure that it still-- it
really lives within the
realm of what's possible.
And if we conclude that
it does, then we dig in
and we work on it usually
for a year, sometimes more.
And it's hard, it's really hard.
And it's hard because there's
no precedence for what we do.
There's just nothing out
there like that before.
And so we have to invent things.
We have to invent new materials.
We have to invent
new testing rigs.
We have to invent new
software concepts.
And we often hit roadblocks,
and we stumble, and we fall.
And we get back up again,
and we fight, and we persist.
And we do it because
it's important,
and because we
believe in this idea.
And then something
magical happens,
we see this little glimmer of
light at the end of the tunnel.
And we think, holy cow this
thing that was just an idea
may be real.
And we go to the lab, and
it's there, and it exists.
And at that moment, we turn to
developers, such as yourselves,
and commercial partners, and
we ask one simple question.
If we can make this thing
exist, not just in a lab,
but in the real world,
what would you do with it.
What could you build,
what products could it be,
how could we impact
people's lives.
How do we get things
into the hands of people.
But most importantly, we
ask them a simple question.
Do you want to come on
this journey with us?
And when they say yes,
things begin to change.
They inject all
sorts of new energy,
they have all sorts
of ideas, they
want to take our technology
places we never imagined.
We encounter all
sorts of new problems
that we never thought of before.
And more importantly,
they come up
with solutions to these
problems that blow our minds.
And all of a sudden
these fledgling ideas
start to become prototypes.
And prototypes become products.
So success for us is when our
projects make this transition.
Because after all
for things to matter,
people have to be
able to use them.
Now these transitions happen
in many different ways.
I'm going to give you
three brief examples,
we've had a whole
bunch of these.
But three may give you a feel.
So about two years
on the I/O stage,
Johnny Lee wondered, if we
could map the indoor world
the same way Google can
map the outside world,
and he showed a
couple of prototypes.
Well now with the help of
Clay Bavor and the VR team,
they took Tango from
these early prototypes,
that we shared at
I/O to a product
you'll be able to buy later
this year from Lenovo.
Yeah, go buy one.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Last year, we
talked about Project Abacus.
This was Deepak
Chandra's vision,
to get rid of passwords and
all of the annoying things
that we wanted.
And he thought, gee,
look we have a phone,
and these phones have all
these sensors in them.
Why couldn't it just
know who I was, so I
don't need a password, I
should just be able to work.
Well, thanks to our friends
at Search and Machine
Intelligence, they've
taken these ideas,
and they've turned
it into a trust API.
And what we're going
to do with this,
is be able to get rid
of the awkwardness
of second-factor authentication.
This June, we're going
out to several very large
financial institutions
for initial testing.
And assuming it goes
well, this should
become available
to every Android
developer around the world
by the end of the year.
I cannot wait to see what
you guys build with it.
Now, sometimes this
transition-- you know,
transitions don't happen
on a schedule, right.
Sometimes they just pop
up and surprise you,
and so I wanted to
share this one with you,
because nobody's ever seen
it outside of our shop.
A while ago, we were
looking at this slide.
And this is a very complex
slide, so don't worry about it.
Here's the bottom line.
There is an epidemic in
congestive heart failure,
and it costs us millions of
lives and billions of dollars.
And what we do today to
help people with that,
is we do surgery,
and we use what
we call an invasive sensor.
So you do surgery, and you
put a sensor in the chest,
and then it helps
monitor people's health.
And we saw this as a problem.
And we wondered, if I could
replace these invasive sensors
with noninvasive sensors,
wouldn't that be amazing.
All of a sudden, the cost
of health care would drop.
We could give this to everybody.
You wouldn't need
surgery, which is risky.
And we shared that
vision with Andy Conrad,
and Jessica Mega, who were at
the time, all part of Google
Life Sciences, now Verily.
And they love that vision.
And so we've transitioned our
people, and our technology,
and the IP, because
we want to get this
developed as fast as possible.
And we could not
think of anybody
who's better off to do that.
So hopefully, you will get
this in everybody's hands
as soon as possible.
So for us, that's what
success looks like.
Because after all, ideas
are most meaningful
when put into practice.
So today, that's what
I want to focus on.
I want to focus on this
journey that we take you on.
From an early idea, to
a prototype, to just
the beginning glimmers of
a commercial application.
So let's get started.
Last year, Dr. Ivan
Poupyrev introduced us
to two projects, project
Soli and project Jacquard.
And over the past
year, Ivan and his team
have been working with
commercial partners
and developers, and to
give you an idea of where
we are on that journey, and for
an update, Dr. Ivan Poupyrev.
[APPLAUSE]
IVAN POUPYREV: Thank you, Dan.
Good morning.
So let's talk about project
Soli and project Jacquard.
In project Jacquard that
was announced last year,
we develop a new interactive
Textile Technology
to create connected clothes.
We also announced
partnership with Levis.
And there is a lot
of speculation--
[APPLAUSE]
DAN KAUFMAN: There we go.
And there is a lot of
speculation, what are
they going to make with them.
So let's look at one of them.
MALE SPEAKER: Apparently,
Google is developing
a new digital type of
fabric that you can touch,
and it can feel it.
And it also Bluetooth's
to your phone.
So now you can swipe the side of
your jeans to mute your phone.
Even tap the fabric for
playing any song, which
means pretty soon all your
calls can be butt dials.
[LAUGHTER]
IVAN POUPYREV: Butt
dials, seriously.
That's a million
dollar idea for you.
Almost accurate, except
we're not making smart pants.
No folks, no smart pants.
Instead, the very
first Jacquard garment
is going to be Levi's
commuter trucker jacket,
fashionable and functional.
[APPLAUSE]
Fashionable and
functional garment
to wear on and off the bike.
And to tell you why commuter
jacket is a perfect fit
for Jacquard, I would
like to invite on stage,
Paul Dillinger, VP of
Innovation from Levi's.
Welcome, Paul.
PAUL DILLINGER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Thanks very much for
that introduction.
But we actually
already met, right.
It's hard to believe it was just
a year ago at Google I/O '15,
when we were first introduced.
It's also hard to believe
it's been 143 years,
since Levi Strauss first
invented the blue jean.
That's today, May 20th, is
the actual official birthday
of the blue jean.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
So for 143 years
at Levi's, we've
been making clothing
with purpose.
It started in the 1800s,
making durable clothing
for the miners who had
come out for the gold rush.
Fast forward to 2011, we first
introduced our Levi's commuter
collection.
It's a purposeful design.
Clothing built for the-- to meet
the needs of the urban cyclist.
But the formula has
always been simple,
make a quality clothes that
perform as great as they look.
And so it's in that context,
I'm excited to talk to you
about today's newest addition
to the commuter family,
which is the trucker jacket
powered by Google's Jacquard
technology.
Anyone who rides a bike,
knows that tension.
How do you go on a ride
without going off grid.
Anyone who owns a bike--
anyone who rides a bike
knows that it's a
terrible idea to try
to navigate the
screen of your phone,
while you're navigating
busy city streets.
But this technology gives us a
first time real world solution
to that real world problem.
Now if you imagine the
opportunity for a woven tactile
interface in the context of the
most explicit and urgent needs
of an urban cyclist, that's
safety and awareness.
The opportunity becomes really
real and really valuable.
This becomes a copilot for
your ride and for your life,
both on and off the bike.
This is a good friend
helping you out.
So now, to access the
most necessary pieces
of your digital life,
you simply touch
the sleeve of your jacket.
This is a customized
kind of activity.
This is maximized awareness
and minimized distraction.
And all of this
without sacrificing
the style of a great looking
Levis trucker jacket.
So now, if you want
to answer a phone call
or block a phone call, if you
want to control your music,
if you want to
drop a pin to make
your personal map
of the city, if you
want to access your navigation
so you can get lost and then
get found-- all of that
can be done with just
a gesture, a tap, a swipe.
Now you might think that
this kind of technology
would be precious.
But we're not making
Levis trucker gadgets,
we're making trucker
jackets, jean jackets,
this is a tough technology.
At the end of the day, you can
just wad it up and throw it
in your backpack.
You don't have to hang it up,
just drop it on the floor.
If you get this thing dirty, you
put it in the washing machine.
This is friendly,
easy going technology.
This is technology you can wash.
But enough out of me.
I think we should take a look
at this jacket in action.
So let's watch a video.
I'm going to throw one on and
come back and talk you guys
about some of the features, OK.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
IVAN POUPYREV: So Paul
going to come back and show
the jacket in a second.
And before that, let's
take a deeper look
at what Google Jacquard is.
Google Jacquard is a platform.
It's not just another
wearable, it's
a platform to create
smart connected clothes.
It consists of the garment,
with a woven gesture
sensor somewhere in the cuff.
A piece of electronics,
or Jacquard tag,
which connects your
jacket to the LED,
haptics, IMU sensor, and
also the batteries to power
the jacket.
It uses custom connection
in the cuff to do that.
The Jacquard can be
charged from any use cable.
So in his computer, so you don't
need a cable with the jacket.
We also have a Jacquard
app on the phone,
which connects your jacket
to services in the cloud.
There is a unique challenge
in creating smart clothing
platform.
Fashion technology
has to work as one,
but there is inherent
tension between the two.
For example, when we designed
our jacket for the first time,
we were compromising
garment and aesthetics.
The first design
of interactive area
was like this, straight line.
We are engineers, we
like things simple.
Everything is
visible, everything
is easy to understand.
However, this is not denim.
It was not authentic,
and it didn't look good.
So then we did-- went the
other way around and removed it
completely, made it
completely invisible.
But now you cannot
interact with that.
So we were working with our
craftsmen in Japan and Levis,
and designed a new
look, new denim
weaving techniques,
which blended
gesture sensing to fabric.
Made it both visible
and invisible,
while preserving an
authentic denim look.
In fashion, fit matters.
You have to design technology,
which fits jackets of any size,
from extra small to extra large.
You probably don't have
a technology world.
That's why our Jacquard
tag is feeling flexible,
so you can bend around
the cuff of any size,
and fit the jacket of any size.
The design was inspired by
the design of a classic trench
coat.
And though it looks
simple, it was a long road
to make it just right.
It has to be robust.
Technology is fragile.
Garments, as Paul mentioned
are not, very durable.
Now, these days you don't have
to pull them with two horses
to prove that it really works.
Those days are behind us.
But we have to be able to
wash it, at the very least.
In our first test,
our yarns would
break after one or two washes.
So we went on and worked
hard to understand
the reason of failure,
we'd analyze our yarns
at the microscope.
And then prove them
to the point where
we exceeded the
Levi's requirements
for jacket durability.
We don't have to treat
Jacquard jacket any differently
from regular jacket.
Finally, clothes are
made by apparel makers,
not by consumer
electronics makers.
It's our vision that any
apparel maker, not only Levis,
should be able to manufacture
their own smart garments using
Jacquard.
Using their own supply
chain, because we
want to empower the
apparel industry to create
this new product platform.
So we work with Levis,
we setup production
in the same facilities,
in the same location
as the regular mass production.
We use the same denim
looms, and exactly the same
processes to weave
our interactive denim.
There was no exception.
When you make denim, you
burn excessive fibers
with open flames.
Our interactive technology
went through the same thing.
Finally, then it was shipped
in the same assembly factory,
the same treatments, the
same construction techniques
as a regular denim jacket.
Industrial washing, every
garment goes through that.
Of course, we added
some testing facilities
to understand quality control,
see it works at the exit.
But at the end, it's
a regular jacket.
It feels good and
makes you look great.
[APPLAUSE]
I guess I want to say is that,
Jacquard jackets is foremost,
a jacket.
It protects you from wind
and rain, keeps you warm,
and makes you look great.
But much more than a jacket.
As a user of the
jacket, you will
be able to configure it to
connect your favorite services,
such as control calls and
messages from the phone,
or use your favorite Google
services, Google Maps, Google
Play, or others.
You can use third-party services
such as Spotify and Strava
and we are already
working with third parties
to include their
support to the jacket.
And finally, it can be custom
services developed by you,
by developers.
And we will be releasing
APIs to allow you to do that.
Furthermore, we are trying to
expand to go beyond biking,
and going to work
with athletics,
business wear, and enterprise.
But first things first.
Our jacket is going
to be released
on the market in Spring 2017.
[APPLAUSE]
Now, you don't have
to wait that long.
And you can help us to
improve the product by joining
the beta in Fall 2016.
And now let's take a
look at the jacket.
[APPLAUSE]
PAUL DILLINGER: I'll
set this right here.
There we go.
So it's a Jean jacket, right.
It's had some great
formal modifications,
the forms have
been adapted to be
most useful for the cyclists.
For example, little
things like the backs
a little longer than the front.
So you don't have
that unfortunate gap
when you're in your bike stance.
It's also got a full flex
extension in the back,
so you've got maximum
range of motion.
And localized venting to
keep you cool and comfortable
on your ride.
It's got a neat storm cuff right
here, so that it holds close
against your wrist, and doesn't
let wind come up your sleeve
when you're on your bike.
But the real magic happens
over here, on this sleeve.
So
IVAN POUPYREV: Yeah,
as you can see.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL DILLINGER:
You can see, fully
responsive to the touch of
the wearer against the--
it's just the fabric.
So there's a bunch of
different things it can do,
so Ivan, let's pick a
few that this will--
IVAN POUPYREV: Yeah,
so this is a kind of,
this is an application, which
is installed in the jacket
right now.
It's good for the
[INAUDIBLE] burn counter.
PAUL DILLINGER: No, thank you.
I don't need the
burn counter today.
IVAN POUPYREV: So we
have music-- we installed
music and compass for you.
So you can control this.
Music and compass are
pretty much all I need.
I love to listen to
music on my bike.
I don't listen to this
song hardly on my--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
There we go.
That's my bike jam, OK.
[APPLAUSE]
Now, my next meeting
after this is going
to be over at Levi stadium.
I know how to get
there, but I'd just
like to know how long
it's going to take me.
IVAN POUPYREV: Yeah, good idea.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
FEMALE SPEAKER: Your
ETA is 41 minutes,
you should arrive by 11:01 am.
PAUL DILLINGER: All right,
IVAN POUPYREV: You've got to go.
PAUL DILLINGER: OK, I got to go.
If I'm going to
make that ride, I
got to get out of
here, all right.
IVAN POUPYREV:
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
So with Jacquard, we
created new materials
that allow us to use
embedded interactions
in everyday objects,
such as clothing.
In our next project,
project Soli.
We explore how can we use
a small set of fine finger
gestures to control
everything around us.
In technical terms, Soli can be
described as a small tiny pica
radar for gesture sensing.
It's a radar, and we
created new radar sensors,
running at 60 GHz, that can
track hand gestures using novel
algorithms that we developed.
The algorithm,
extremely fine-- allows
to track really fine gestures,
such as rubbing your fingers
against each other, which
allows us to create completely
new gesture languages
and gesture interfaces.
So we develop a vision where
your hand is the only control
that you need.
One movement is a virtual
dial or slider or button.
And these are just
virtual controls.
You should be able to
control any device around you
with the same set of
gestures-- wearables, speakers,
or any other objects,
internet of the things world.
We showed this
recently last year
at Google I/O. And showed
the proof of concept.
And the potential of Soli
captured people's imagination.
It feels very futuristic,
almost science fiction.
So this year, after
last Google I/O,
we focus on bringing
the science fiction
vision into the reality, to
developers, into products.
That was our goal.
Our first step was really the
Soli Development Kit, which
we did in October last year.
And the kit included
everything that you
need to develop your
products or projects--
hardware, software
libraries, documentations,
everything you need.
It was early work, so we
selected about 60 developers,
from 180 applications, coming
from 14 foreign countries.
And we were quite encouraged by
the diversity of the projects
people built using our sensors.
In this example, people using
Soli to recognize materials,
such as copper or milk or water.
People use it for 3D imaging.
People drawing in
touch interaction,
in-car remote
control, the control
to lock your things, security
and password with gestures,
navigate visualizations,
and compose and play music.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
So this selection-- very
first selection, very first
few projects developed
by developers
using our Soli sensor.
And developing launching
Soli for all of alpha dev kit
was an important milestone.
It was the first of its
kind, the first radar
you can play in your own
workshop or research lab.
However, it was
just a first step.
What we showed last
year, was designed
to run in controlled
environment, in a research lab,
in a workshop.
It can allow it to relate
possibilities of the radar
for interaction, but you cannot
really build products with it.
For example, it was
using so much power
that our legal
department asked me
to put this label on the back
of the-- of the development kit.
Although the Soli
chip is very small,
they still require a
large computer to run it.
And so it kind of defeats
the purpose-- small chip,
giant computer.
So to prove that Soli is not
just a futuristic concept,
it can work outside of the lab.
We decided that by
this Google I/O, not
only are we going
to improve it, we're
going to make it run
it on a smartwatch.
[APPLAUSE]
So the way I think
about it, if you
can make something
run on smartwatch,
you can make it run
any way you want.
So setting this kind
of goal, what it does,
it creates such an
impulse to the team,
that the progress is
exponential, not incremental.
For example, we had to
drastically decrease the size
and power of the entire system.
By working with our
partners at Infinium,
we completely redesign
the Soli chip.
We optimized [INAUDIBLE] control
algorithms overall system
architecture, and reduce
power consumption 22 times,
from 1.2 Watt to 54 milliWatt.
[APPLAUSE]
And this is just a first
step in our optimization.
We also reduced
footprint three times.
Now reducing power
is not sufficient.
As I mentioned, there's a
giant computer around the Soli.
So we also had to
optimize computization.
Now radars are naturally very
computizationally expensive,
often require a supercomputer
for the imaging and tracking,
when tracking satellites or
planes or something like that.
Now we don't have supercomputer,
this is our embedded platform,
it uses the same
processors as a watch.
So by optimizing our
signal processing
pipeline, and
algorithms, we were
able to achieve 256x reduction
in the code performance,
while maintaining 80,000
frames per second throughput
of the radar.
So you don't have to compromise
your performance for small form
factor.
And by the way, it's
all run through Android.
[APPLAUSE]
However, nothing is
free in this world.
And there are trade-offs.
And I want to talk
about one of them.
With every hardware reduction,
with every improvement
of our algorithms, we
changed the radar signal,
and this is something,
which is called glitches,
a collection of signal
artifacts that we discover
and have to find a work around.
Some of them are well-known
research literature,
such as IQ channel
imbalance, Doppler
mirror images, ghost targets.
But a lot of this ghost--
a lot of those glitches
are new, and the result of
our aggressive reduction
of the hardware and software.
So this is ongoing research
and development work.
Now this-- I can talk more about
the challenges and problems.
But let's get to the watch.
Let's show the watch.
This is the first
watch we developed.
It doesn't look like a watch.
Working with our partners
in LG electronics company,
from LG Electronics
Research team,
we actually built the first
watch and it put like that.
At this time, this time radar
was embedded into the band--
into the belt of the watch.
We see it in the field,
it looks like a watch.
You have to have this
black thing, which
doesn't bend around your wrist.
So we went on and shrink
radar hardware further.
So this is a very
tiny chip on the left.
And here it is, a watch
with Soli radar inside.
[APPLAUSE]
And I have it on my wrist, too.
It can even show time.
That's how awesome
technology is.
So now our goal is not to
create just a smartwatch,
but to create
unique interactions.
And I would like to invite
Nick Gillian, our lead Machine
Engineer, Machine Learning
Engineer to show how it works.
But before he shows
it, let me kind of
give you a preview of what
you'll be seeing on the screen.
What Soli allows
to do is to expand
interaction over the touchscreen
into the 3D space around it.
So you don't have to use
a tiny screen to interact
with what you watch.
You don't have to try
to hit small targets,
use the whole space around
the watch to interact.
So we split the space
into two big parts.
To interact with
information on the watch,
we use large gestures
around the watch.
So you can move like this, and
you can scroll through messages
or see parts of the interface,
parts of information.
And if you want to navigate
the interface of the watch,
you can use virtual tools.
As we talked about
before, virtual dials
and virtual buttons, so you can
put your hand next to the watch
and use them to navigate
interaction and interface
elements.
So let's take a look
at how it works.
And I'm going to get
Nick Gillan to show it.
Nick up to you.
NICK GILLIAN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
OK, let's take a
look at the watch.
You can see, as my
hand approaches,
it dynamically starts to react.
[APPLAUSE]
Note how the responsiveness
and precision of radar
enables us to create these
continuous fluid interactions.
The blue bar here, you can see,
corresponds to my proximity
to the device.
This enables me to glance at
information at a distance.
So here for example, I can see
I've got 4 unread messages.
If I come a little
closer, I can now
see the names of the
users who sent them.
The precision of Soli enables me
to interact with minute detail,
such as this
scrolling typography.
If I move a little
closer, I can now
preview the contents
of the first message.
You can see how Soli allows
us to take the contents
on the display, and
actually move them
to the space around the watch.
And if I remove my hand,
it dynamically resets.
OK, but what if I want to
interact with more detail.
That's easy.
I just move my hand
closer to the watch,
and now I can use a
virtual dial gesture
to interact with
the complications.
[APPLAUSE]
So here you can see, I'm
using a virtual dial gesture
to rotate through these
various complications.
So we got the messages, the
weather, and the calendar.
These gestures
represent interactions
with physical controls, such
as using an analog dial.
Because I don't have
to touch the screen,
we can get a lot more
information on the display.
And of course, just because
they're micro gestures,
doesn't mean I have to do
them right next to the device,
they also work at a distance.
So let's select one of
the other applications.
The weather, for example,
I remove my hand.
And now I want to
come back in, I
can instantly look at what the
next weather information is.
So you can see with just
a few Soli gestures,
we can already start to build
these rich interactions.
Soli embedded fully
on a smart watch.
Back to Ivan.
[APPLAUSE]
IVAN POUPYREV: So
Nick, stay onstage.
[APPLAUSE]
We have another demo, and
you are going to show it.
You're very good at that.
So when you are building
Soli just for smartwatches,
we think of it as a generic
interaction platform
to control all sorts of
devices, with a very simple set
of simple gestures.
So to explore the use of
Soli beyond the wearables,
we decided to take
it to the living
room, in collaboration with
Harman, and their JBL brand.
So here Soli allows the control
of home devices from a distance
without touching them.
This is the very first
prototype is here with speakers,
very early work.
But the idea here is exactly
the same interaction principles,
and the same gestures that
we designed for watch, also
allow us to control the speaker.
We can see.
It's a different embodiment,
but the principle is the same.
As it approaches
his hand, you can
see that the speaker
recognizes and reacts to it.
So what are you
going to next, Nick?
NICK GILLIAN: Yeah, so note
that the interactions here
are much larger than the
watch, they are several feet.
The sensor actually can
sense up to around 15 meters.
So we can do some pretty
amazing stuff with this.
And this is the same
thing that's in the watch.
IVAN POUPYREV: Same algorithms.
NICK GILLIAN: So as I approach,
I can now use the virtual tool
to turn it on.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
OK, let's try another track.
[MUSIC PLAYING] NICK
GILLIAN: What do you think?
The next one?
[BEPEPING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Yeah, that's pretty cool.
OK, but I can also
do other gestures.
More immediate ones,
like shut it out.
IVAN POUPYREV: Great,
thank you very much.
NICK GILLIAN: Thanks everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
IVAN POUPYREV:
Thank you to Nick.
So to conclude, Soli is
interaction and platform
for connecting the world.
It proposes new universal
interaction experience
across multiple connected
products of the future.
It can be wearable , mobile,
internet of things, automotive,
industrial-- it's all
up to your imagination.
What it does, it offers
a third dimension
of interaction, which
compliments and enhances
other interaction modalities,
such as touch screen and voice
input.
We don't fight with
them, we work together.
And working with our partners,
such as Harman, LG, and others.
We want to bring this new
experience to products.
But you don't have to wait
until it becomes a product.
Next year we're launching
the next version
of a Soli development kit.
The Soli beta dev kit.
And this will be
embedded, low power,
and based on module design.
So what you're going to have
is Soli going to be this size.
And you can put it in
your products or projects,
and explore the use of Soli
in your ideas and our designs.
So we're looking forward
to exploring Soli with you.
And that was Soli.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
DAN KAUFMAN: Pretty cool.
Yeah.
Thanks to Nick
and Ivan and Paul.
But mostly thanks
to Levi's, do I
have the coolest job
in the world or what.
All right, so I promised
you we would talk about Ara.
And for those of you
who may be new here,
Ara is our vision for
the future of phones.
And even more so, our vision
for an entirely new hardware
ecosystem.
For those of you who have been
following Ara for a while,
you may be wondering,
what's going on with Ara.
Where is it?
And most importantly,
when do I get one?
AUDIENCE: Woo.
DAN KAUFMAN: Yeah, woo.
So, well, Ara has made so
much progress over the year,
and we've talked about
this journey from concept,
to prototype, to product.
It's made so much
progress this year,
it's actually spun out
into its own business unit.
It's spinning out of Ara,
into another business unit
inside of Google, with
our boss Rick, who's here.
Thanks for coming.
And it's going to be run
by Richard Woolridge.
And here to tell you more
about it and the progress
that we've made, Rafa Camargo.
[APPLAUSE]
RAFA CAMARGO: Thank you, Dan.
All right, for the
last year, we've
been working with users,
developers, and partners.
As a result, we've implemented
a new set of technologies
to create a seamless
modular experience.
Most importantly, we put
modularity where it counts.
Let's take a look.
This is the developer's
edition of Ara.
[APPLAUSE]
We've integrated the phone
technology in the frame,
that frees up space for mobiles,
that will create and integrate
new functionality that you
cannot get on your smartphone
today.
It has six modular slots.
They're built for flexibility.
You can put any
module, anywhere.
All the slots are generic,
and support any functionality.
Each slot supports up to
11.6 gigabytes per second,
while consuming one
third of the USB3 power.
They are interconnected
via UniPro network.
That allows you for example,
to route raw 4K video directly
to a computer
vision co-processor
for real-time processing.
It's ready for the most advanced
high performance applications.
Modules are designed to work
with a variety of form factors.
Future frames can be
larger, they can be smaller,
or something completely
different than a smartphone.
Current modules will
work with future frames.
Future mobile will work
with current frames.
Protecting the investment
of both users and developers
in modulars.
So how do you add
functionality to your Ara.
Step one, plug in a module.
Step two, use it.
OK, guys.
Smile.
There we go.
It is that simple, that easy.
No rebooting your device,
no hunting for drivers.
And how do you remove a module.
Well, you select the
module you want to release,
from the settings up.
Pop it.
And then when I turn
it, so it doesn't fall,
it's just going to pop.
Oh.
I may have gone too far on
that, let me try that again.
Let's try a different one.
OK, Google, eject the camera.
[POP]
[APPLAUSE]
There you go.
And put it back.
[APPLAUSE]
Over this last year--
All right.
[APPLAUSE]
Over this last year,
we build a tech,
not just for a smartphone, but
for a truly modular computing
platform.
Our silicone has implemented the
world's first UniPro network.
High speed, low
power, and application
independent, future
proof and designed
from the ground up for mobile.
The modular connector is
built for the speed of UniPro,
and it's robust, up to
10,000 connect cycles.
And the electromechanical
latch built with nitinol memory
alloy, in control
from software, as you
saw, creating an intuitive
modular release experience.
Greybus, the Ara software
stack, enables runtime detection
and use of modules.
You just plug it, and it works.
And we have abstracted all
this technology in a baseplate.
So developers can focus
on their technology,
while users will be guaranteed a
consistent user experience when
using our modulars.
The baseplate is the hardware
equivalent of a software API.
Ara is an open platform.
We want to create a hardware
ecosystem on the scale
of the software up ecosystem.
And to talk about what
we're doing with modules,
and what's next with
Ara is Blaise Bertrand,
our Head of Creative.
[APPLAUSE]
BLAISE BERTRAND:
Thank you, Rafa.
Good morning, everybody.
So as we've been
developing the phone,
we've also been
creating modules.
And we started with modules
that improve current phone
functionalities-- better
speakers, high resolution
cameras, and expandable storage.
But we also wanted
to make Ara personal.
So we've developed modules with
woods, modules with concrete,
and modules that we
added color to it.
We've also been exploring
secondary displays,
various types of sensors,
and new technologies
that you can find
on phones today.
Ara is the combination
of beauty and function.
But it's also about solving
specific user needs.
Diabetes, over six million adult
Americans, who have Diabetes,
check their glucose level
several times a day, OK.
And for that, they have
to carry many devices--
a phone and a glucometer.
It turns out that pretty much
everything in a glucometer,
besides a few sensors,
is also in a phone.
So we thought hey,
what if we could
put all this into a module to
create a better glucometer.
Well, you know, it'd
be in your phone,
so it would be a lot
more compact, right.
And you could also add context
to your measurement by showing,
for instance, if you're
reading was done after sitting
or after exercising.
Now the great news
with Ara is that we
don't have to go it alone.
As a matter of
fact, we have been
partnering with best
in class companies
to develop modules with us.
Companies that are already
familiar with a modular space.
Samsung Electro-Mechanics,
Micron, Sony Pictures Home
Entertainment, E Ink, Panasonic,
Wistron, TDK, Toshiba,
and Harman.
But other great companies that
build great products, and never
had the chance and
the opportunity
to have their
technology on phones.
Companies like Cohero,
iHealth, BACtrack, and goTenna.
So now we have a phone,
we have a set of modules,
and we have great
market partners.
Well, now we need your help.
So later this year
we'll be launching
the Developer Edition of Ara.
It will contain a
phone, a few modules,
well specially anything
you need to start building.
So we'd like to ask you to think
about, what are the modules
that you want to create.
But there's more to come.
We've been working on the
consumer version of Ara.
It will be thin, it will be
light, it will be beautiful.
And we'll launch it next year.
Meanwhile, I'd like to give you
a glimpse of what life with Ara
could be like.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAN KAUFMAN: So thanks
to Rafa and Blaise.
But, you know, Rafa and I have
worked together for a while.
And you'd think he would
know a lot better than this,
because he always says the
key is making Ara yours.
And he left it up here,
well Ara's now mine.
Thank you.
So as we said, we
wanted to end the show
with talking a little bit
about Spotlight Stories.
And one of the
reasons we want to do
that is a core tenet
of ATAP is to remember
not to lose the human inside of
all this technological wonder.
In two years ago, at AI,
Disney legend Glen Keane,
enchanted all of us
as he drew on stage
and brought to life a
duet before our very eyes.
And last year, we had Justin
Lin's live action alien
takeover L.A. in 360, and
that shook our I/O session.
Well this year, we have a
really special treat for you.
But I can think of no better
way to talk about our latest
spotlight story, than just
introducing Rachid El Guerrab.
[APPLAUSE]
RACHID EL GUERRAB:
Thank you, Dan.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
So 2016, has been a big
year for 360 and VR.
Enthusiasts have
their early headsets,
and 360 video and cameras
are now becoming mainstream.
The one question that keeps
coming up over and over
is, can we tell stories
in this new medium?
Can we make films,
like the ones we love
and the ones that move us?
And we've been working
on this for a while
now, before 360 cameras
and before the new VR.
And besides all the efforts
for capturing or creating
an immersive world around you,
we cannot forget one important
and essential factor
in storytelling.
The stories have setups,
complications, resolutions.
They have beginnings,
middles, and ends
that need to make sense.
And a structure, without
which we're easily confused,
or maybe not interested.
And what's most
important for being
able to tell a story
to an audience,
is managing their attention.
It's easy for me to get
your attention, right now.
I'm here on the stage and
you're sitting in your chairs,
facing the right way.
And you know that the next
thing is going to happen here.
But when you're immersed in
a story, it's all around you.
But how do we tell you,
where should you look.
How do we tell you where the
next thing is going to happen?
How do would keep you
from getting lost,
or just missing an important
moment in the story?
Google Spotlight Stories
came out of this challenge.
Of being able to create
immersive stories
with a structured narrative.
And giving filmmakers
the tools so they
can get the right impact from
their story, even when you
the viewer are in
control of the camera.
And we do that through
interactive techniques.
That are attuned to manage
and respond to your attention,
as you're watching,
without you noticing.
We call it attentioneering.
Let me give you some examples.
Our stories will wait for
you to look the right way.
And where it's easy to get
lost in a big 360 video,
our camera will
dynamically guide you
without taking control,
to get the best
framing for the action.
Like here, we see you're
interested in this monster
and so will keep you on it.
And if you get
lost in the clouds.
We will not only reward
you with a change of music,
but a helpful actor will come
over and help you and guide you
back to the main story.
And if you're just
still curious,
and want to look around.
Well you might discover
subplots, gags,
and other scenes, because this
world is alive around you.
Sometimes you have to
watch it over and over
before you get all of them.
And we know these
techniques work,
because we partnered with
award-winning filmmakers,
masters of their craft.
And we created actual
films in CGI animation,
in classic hand-drawn
animation, and even
Hollywood scale live-action.
And with our story
Development Kit,
award-winning studios use
these and other techniques
to create their own films.
And push immersive
storytelling even further,
without one line of code.
In three years, eight
immersive interactive films
with different styles
and different voices,
it's a VR film festival.
Now, with the enthusiastic
reception from the animation
and film communities, but more
importantly, millions of people
have already experienced
these stories
through the window
of phone screen,
with VR viewers like Cardboard,
and now with big VR headsets.
All these different films run on
a tiny but powerful game engine
doing real-time graphics and
animation, 360 video and audio,
and enabling film-like
content in real-time
on mobile hardware.
This engine was squeezed
to less than 1 megabyte
of code, smaller than a codec.
[APPLAUSE]
And was delivered to
billions of devices
on one of the largest online
video platforms, YouTube,
where these interactive
non-linear films are as
accessible as a regular video.
Now last Christmas, we
launched our first YouTube
interactive shorts
called Special Delivery
from renowned studio
Aardman Animations.
Unlike a linear video, the
full environment of the show
had to be streamed and
reconstructed on your device
in less than one second.
Because it's 3D
and it's real-time,
and you can look anywhere from
the first moment you see it.
With our latest story,
we pushed our compression
and non-linear streaming
techniques way further.
26 different
environments, each one
bigger than the whole
of the other story,
each one lasting only
for a few seconds.
And this is the first
show where we continuously
cut from one shot
to the next, 38
shots in less than six minutes.
And the engine has to throw away
a full environment every time,
and bring in a new one each
time, seamlessly, perfect sync,
without a hitch.
And more so with four ambisonic
tracks, specialized music,
and stereo music, and
3D positional audio,
this was the most complex and
rewarding sound experience
we've ever created.
The story is called
"Pearl" and it's
premiering today on YouTube.
[APPLAUSE]
Now, before you go check it out.
I would like you to hear
from the director himself.
He's known for animation on
big Disney films like "Wreck-it
Ralph," "Tangled",
and "Big Hero 6."
And he was supervising animator
on an Academy Award-winning
shorts called "Paper Man."
Last year, he picked up
his own Academy Award
for a beautiful animated
short called "Feast."
And of course, what do you do
after you win an Academy Award,
you make a Spotlight Story.
So ladies and gentleman,
the creator of "Pearl",
Patrick Osborne.
[APPLAUSE]
PATRICK OSBORNE: Thanks, Rachid.
So a little over a
year ago, I showed up
for my first time at Google,
right down the street here
and met the amazing
minds at ATAP.
And I took over one of their
famed whiteboard covered
conference rooms and
began to draw up an idea.
And I wanted to make something
memorable, beautiful,
and maybe meaningful.
And I didn't know
it then, but I was
very lucky to have met
this particular group,
these geniuses at ATAP.
Because I didn't know it yet,
but I was asking for something
that was really hard,
maybe impossible to do.
I wanted to make this short
Pearl a 6-minute fully animated
360-degree short, road
trip musical, that
takes place entirely in
a beat up 1980 sedan.
With 15 characters,
more environments
than many feature
films, and just
creating designing and creating
that many sets is a lot
to handle, but on
top of that they
need to be rendered in
real-time on a phone.
And apparently that's hard.
So my background is animation.
And I've been working in feature
films for the last 13 years.
And animators are
control freaks.
We make everything from
scratch in every scene.
But this mobile
platform was different.
It was going to be a
film without a frame.
The audience-- not
me, the director,
gets to decide where
the camera goes,
and that feels like a lot of
control to give up at first.
But I thought about maybe
turning those limitations
into something that
would inspire the story.
So filmmakers been
using artificial frames
within frames since
the beginning of time
or the beginning of film.
If we set this film
entirely in a car,
I could get my fill of
these pretty compositions
by making frames with the
car windows themselves.
So what kind of story
takes place in a car?
I love road trip movies,
so I thought maybe
we would make one of those.
And let the audience
sit-in the passenger seat.
And treat it more like
theater than film,
where I try to
spotlight the action
and direct the attention
of the audience.
But its completely
OK if they wander.
And I made sure the story
would read, no matter
what direction they were
looking, even if you're not
looking the right way.
So it would be some sort of road
trip giving tree kind of story.
Maybe a story about
passing down your car.
And I thought what
else do we pass on?
Personality tastes
and talent, maybe.
I used to draw with
my dad as a kid.
He's a toy designer.
And I think more than any
of the physical things
he gave me, including my high
school '89 Civic hatchback,
the most thing--
the thing I value
most is the time
we spent together
drawing when I was a kid.
He passed on a sense
of visual taste.
And the love of
putting pen to paper.
And I think considering
what I do now,
it's probably the most
valuable thing he ever gave me.
So I decided to make Pearl
that, the story about passing
on an object, your car,
but also handing down
a passion or a talent.
In this case, not drawing,
it was going to be music.
It's going to be a musical.
So it's going to
be a musical, we
need a song to wrap
the whole story around.
And I decided to structure
the story like a pop song
itself-- like verse, chorus,
verse, chorus, bridge.
And this is a little
chart that I handed over
to the composers at Pollen
Music to explain that.
I don't know how
clear it exactly is.
But it was to guide them through
this structure, and this idea
of how that song would be made.
So JJ Wiesler and
Alexis Harte wrote
the beautiful original
song, "No Wrong Way Home."
And it was performed
in the short
by Kelley Stoltz
and Nicki Bluhm.
Now, of course, "Pearl" is out
there in the world right now.
You could pull out your phone
and watch it on YouTube.
But the song being such a core
central part of the story,
I figured it would be
really cool for I/O
to actually bring Kelly
and Nicki here, and do
it live for all of you guys
here and for the world.
[APPLAUSE]
So enjoy "No Wrong Way Home."
[MUSIC - JJ WIESLER AND NICKI
BLUHME, "NO WRONG WAY HOME"]
[APPLAUSE]
DAN KAUFMAN: There is
no way to finish that.
So we're just going
to say, thanks.
And we'll see you
next year at I/O.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]